(music)
(laughter)
- I do have this
sort of secret shame,
that I've only just begun
to share with audiences,
but the night after
this last election,
I accidentally
fucked a Trump voter.
(laughing)
Yeah, no, now hear
me out, I was drunk.
It was last call, he
walked in, he had genitals
and he said let's go,
and halfway back to my
apartment he finally turns to me
and he's like "how
about this election?"
And I was like, oh I can't
believe I didn't ask about this,
it's crazy what's going
to happen to our country,
I'm terrified, and then just
the longest pause imaginable
and he was like, "yeah, but
he has some good ideas."
And I was like, NO!
I feel like I've spent the
last ten years of my life
telling conservatives
online to suck my dick
and then one finally
did, you know,
and I hated it!
(laughter)
Thank you so much, goodnight!
- [Announcer] Now let's hear
it for Joel Kim Booster!
(applause)
(text notification)
- Oh, no!
- I caught a centipede
in the bathroom
(gasp)
holy shit!
- I know, right?
- Oh my god, I don't even
know what to do with that.
- I think I'd need more
than a condom as protection,
like, I wanna take
this dick to court
and get a restraining
order against this penis.
- That's gonna be
a no for me, dog.
- Yeah, no ticket to
Hollywood for this penis.
Come back next season, maybe.
Oh, my car's here.
- Okay, bye!
(smacking lips)
Find a reasonably
sized penis, okay!
- Oh, I did, it's right there!
- Oh, thank you!
(upbeat music)
(text notifications)
- Not much, you?
Not much, you?
- [Emcee] Please help me
welcome to the stage right now,
Shalewa Sharpe!
(applause)
- I'm not used to a New
York City crackhead,
like I'm from the South,
so, a more genteel,
like a crack gentleman
is what I'm used to,
you know what I mean?
(laughter)
Somebody who really cares
about the people
he's stealing from.
My crackhead in Atlanta
once came up to me
and he was like,
"Hey, miss lady,
I really hate to tell you this,
but I caught somebody else
going through your car."
Okay, what is else?
Who?
Else, okay, alright.
(text notifications)
(bar music)
- Yeah, it's dead, right?
So dead.
- Oh, my god, you came?
- Yeah, I came, I
said I was gonna come.
Okay, someone's cute in person.
- Thanks, uh, didn't
you say you were,
like, with a group of people?
- That's a figure of speech.
- Is it?
(laughter)
- So, you're a comedian?
Funny boy.
I bet you are really
funny, I can tell.
- I like to think I am.
(laughter)
- So what is this, is
this like a stand-up,
or is this like improv, or
do you have like a team?
Is it like, happening now,
is it happening later, or
- The show actually happens
in that bar, over there.
This is more like the back
bar where comedians come
to be alone and sort of center
themselves before the set.
- Oh, okay.
- Just be alone,
big part of it.
- Yeah!
Okay well, good thing I came,
because now you have company.
Let's just get a drink, right?
Excuse me, hi, I'd like a drink,
that's why I'm sitting here.
I'd like to not
wait longer, please,
I'd like a Sprite.
- I think he's doing his best.
- Okay, we don't know him
and we don't know that.
- Well, I do, I mean, I see him,
might have to see him a lot.
- Thanks.
- I'm so sorry.
- Okay, so, a little about me,
I have never lost
a Pepsi Challenge.
- Oh, okay, cool.
(bar music)
- So should we go make out?
- So I was coming back from
my father's memorial service,
and a coworker came up to me,
and she said, "Oh, wow, so
both of your parents are gone?"
And I said, "Yeah,
unfortunately that is the case."
And then, she said,
"Wow, don't you wish
you had had kids,
so they could've known
their grandkids?"
(boos)
Biotch!
(laughter)
What?
Okay, I'm just
waiting on a bagel
and you've handed me
an existential crisis.
Thank you, thank you,
good morning, thank you.
(squeaking)
- That is not how my live-in
boyfriend of six years does it.
- Wait, what?
- Nah, its..
- Okay, uhm,
well, thank you so much
for that experience.
But in the meantime, I think
the show is actually happening
right now so I
should probably go.
(laughter)
Is he a ghost?
- This is one of our best
friends, make some noise
- He's the best,
- Joel Kim Booster!
- It's Joel Kim everybody!
- I just would like
to clarify off top
that I am their best friend,
but they're not my best friend.
I just want to set the
record straight really quick.
(electro music)